[Music]
what year are we in
1941
what day is today
[Music]
wednesday i think
very well as briefly as you can
can you read minds
come on in and behold the mysteries of
the universe
i want to give you the world and
everything in it what are you talking
about
we got a little mind reading show
there's a woman abigail oh god
teach me teach you
everybody has some shadow from their
past
oh you're traveling
what if i told you i'd get my hands on a
two-person neck course
what is the object being held a pocket
watch
am i correct
master stanton can you kind of remind
them what's inside the bag
[Applause]
a small pistol
you're not as hard to read as you think
you run a racket same as me
if you help me we can make quite a big
dent in this town
you barely know me
oh i know
you're no good
and i know that good
neither am i
this is not a carnival trick
if your foot slips be both full
we've had our share of snake charmers in
the past we deal with them
what did you do
sometimes you don't see it allowed until
you cross it
he took four people's down
they fool themselves
[Music]
you